[Applaudissements]
facile
[Musique]
James
Je ne me sens pas
Il me semble une extension qui échoue
[Musique]
J'aime dans la relation scientifique
les gens connaissent la privation
c'est possible
[Musique]
bon
bien nous
mes enfants
à tout moment
le système
deux
un cours
6 de ces loups session tunnel le
revenu
il atterrit bien avant l'ancien
ma méthode
c'est moi
comme méthode
reconnaître que le temps de pablo est au travail
elle a tort
Alors
supprimer la relativisation et donc
C'est un jeu d'un jour où tu m'aimes et pas
être un sens
[Musique]
et de plus
Je suis malade
dit l'exécutif
ce rêve saxo acosta stéréo
la ressource ou le hameau
j'ai circulé
où seulement le mien
[Musique]
à cet étage
lorsque
un dessin reste
sexe
je
[Musique]
s'il veut
avec ça
[Musique]
Oh
bien
est laissé de côté
[Musique]
dans son armée
dilate tes yeux
cette
hôtels santayana et pour le sud
pas autant
avec bonjour
dans sa première crise
cette intuition que nous avons trouvée
Voyons voir
de logiciels
cigares à des milliers de scientifiques
poster le point
[Musique]
vous donne des points ou les lingots ci-dessous
ef
[Musique]
l'émotion explique la perception
ef
double charge des indiens et où
pleurer l'argent de l'institut
La succession
[Musique]
s'engager
la notion de frères
André
Oui
est ce que je
et oui cliquez
de la nation
à l'absorption de lexus date de
enlever
il a été parlé
et bien que j'aime
eta
la main
avait cette inclusion
machine femme
ou s'il n'y a pas de réseaux sociaux
avec un temps doux
[Musique]
voyons qu'ils bougent peu de temps dicté
bien
sucre
le cycle de sessions disney
le feuilleton qui dans votre monde
[Musique]
et elle
deux
[Musique]
Oui
avec affichage 7 titres
peut-être avec le bâtard bâtard
bien que la violation même de la délicate
déjà
objets
c'est total
dit qu'il a levé la main et pleuré
la passion familiale a traversé
et tous les anges
ils ont pour un autre
un lent d'or
Remarquez que je pense que je
avec lui
ef
[Musique]
non
et ce n'est pas dit par vous
selon le visage
petite voiture où il est dit que le short
frais pour
pour un disque
parce que c'est
tout pour mourir double assiette
comme il l'a fait avec tes eaux
[Musique]
le moment
en désuétude
où se tenait-il
à peu près
[Musique]
sept
après les écrivains de paola
la folie
alors si le disparu
avril
femmes
contre l'inaction et ses blessures
d'ail séché de la notion de pousse
matière
double demi-succès sont ou ont été atteints
monsieur jean cocteau
dans une partie, ils doivent accomplir le chemin de
comment les rêves
aussi w et carcajou asiatique et genèse
et vous un groupe de riches poètes
voilà c'est au tour
quinze
sa terre
je suis grand
étudier et en action
électrique mon emploi du temps
Comme
quand les lettons m'ont convaincu
[Musique]
le cyclique rapide
Je me lamente sur eux et pleure médicalement
je suis absent comme une page
[Musique]
et si
il s'agissait
- et couvrir tout ce que nous avons 3
dans un joli
selon moins
[Applaudissements]